こんにちははじめ社長ですうまく言えないんですけども
すごい困っていることがありますまず見ていただきたいんですけどもこれが始まったの
がどんくらいだっけな
ちょっと夏に電話してみようっもちろんさん夏
あのさーん俺さぁゆぃ23変なで片山あてきてますこれいつからだっけやんけ
お前枯れないですからなんかもうたぶん3ヶ月前ぐらいで言う屋さんから前からでき
てると思いますなんかねこれ
というわけで今言ったとおりでございますなんか指に変な出来物みたいなのは出来てて
もう3か月くらいずーっととれずに残っています
見ます水に流さの暗いものという認識がないんですけどね
から見るとわかりやすいですよもうポツンってなっててここがほらこれねこれね結構
でかいんですよ
今のでちょっとわかりにくいともからスマホでちょっと気ね
[音楽]
いやーこれなんすかね指に硬いものがって汚くなってて
わーわーって思ってるんですけどどんな花準備の表面にこうやってどんどん出てきて1
か月前くらいに完全に何かもうもうになっちゃって気づいたらもうこんなになってまし
た
あ薬指ですよね以後とかでなんだかこれなんだろ
わかんないんですよなんかその取れる気配でもないし水拭きでって言われるんですけど
水って形でもないんですよ客ガンガンに硬くていい店もないんですよ取ろうと思えば
取れるみたいな感じですこれですよこれ
音の中もとって取るぜ親悪いけどね何回か撮ろうと試したんですけども硬すぎてなんか
ちょっと
よくないんだと思って頑張ってたんですけど今これ結構チャンスだなぁそして動画を
待っている通りつかない
ちょっとってみますえ待ってイタイイタイイタイイタイ理由が結局皮膚くれるんだよね
トルネとルー待っていましていタイプ
いやメリダとれねーなー米無理だってたらすげー怖いよ応援が出たら怖いんですよてか
まずは何なのこれはこれは館内も水辺でとばなら分かります
なんかやけとかしたら作ってだけがわかりますし水ぶくれって形でもないし
まってなんか茶は実は痛いのに立ってるんだけどちょっと享保の原因を突き止めたい
結構困ってますかたいんですよ
ちょっとネットで調べます指8体でって言うかたくなるのは強皮症の症状
俺皮膚科たくなるのかな何か悪い病気の前めでとかの可能性もあるんでちょっと結構
ビビってますてに寄付のできもの
膨らんでいたら
バック欄でいる度というのは腫瘍の大きな特長の一つです
腫瘍
強くなって強くなってきた付出すけど
病院豪華な指のしこりできものそれだ多分
指のしこりとで着物だこれあこれからた子なのでた子じゃないんだよな
菊名角質の増殖が起こり皮膚の表面が熱く硬くなった少女いわゆるたこのこと
たーーーーこうじゃないんだけどペンだこみたいな感じではないんですよね明らかに
異常に飛び出てるんですよねケーナの根元に細菌感染した状態
いや坪の毛穴があるようなもそうでもない気がなかなーとか10月の平内いたはずだと
思うんですけども
手計んだよ
a マってこれがもヘバーデン結節て指の第一関節の指の1番センターの
やば今じゃ関節が腫れたり曲がったりしてときには痛みを伴う状態が大丈夫ですね痛み
は全くないです水ぼうそう
違う水疱瘡は僕なったはずです何わかんないわかん
指にできものができる病気みたいなのって結構多いみたい
ね彼らが画像でたくさんあるなん
[音楽]
ら黒い黒い黒い黒い風呂入らだぶー
今なんか google の画像で日々のできもの揃え0黒い血だらけのばっかでもう
無理
あー早く病院系規模なのかな
いろいろ濰坊なのかなぁーっマティじゃあ調べたんですけど
上見に触るのは ng になってメイミーに触ったり切り取ろうとしたりするとさらに
イボが広がってしまうことがあるためできるだけ触らずに
どうすりゃええのんだってこんなの技で日常的に使えば操作
熱情的に使うところを触れ立ってなくなれば難しいですよ先生
ただもう本当に唯一の好きなのか言いたくないんで特にあっても問題はないんですよね
と油断ならんのですよ
結局皆さん病気っていうのは早期発見が大事なんで本当に誰か助けてください
そもそもこれがいいほうなのかどうかも僕ちょっと調べた感覚でよくわからなかったん
でなんか詳しいかといったら教えてください本当に心配です
とっていいのかとって悪いのかもよくわかんないしてたった一つは彼の本当にね
結構目立つんすよね指でもあっ
いやーマジではから
あんな父よくわかんないんですけどエアーなが変な病気だぜ
性具メーカーはルワンダはこれだーーーっ
手を食べますけど
奪い1
ちょっとよくわかんないけどとコメントなんとか見ていろいろ考えて病院に行こうか
決めます
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ